explain what's happening in co-living
legally illegally what have you seen
don't rat anybody out no yeah yeah sure
um uh i think the jury's out i've seen
i think the two trends i've seen and
some of these people uh use zumpa to
generate demand for co-living
i think we see large consumer demands
uh if i was a vc i'd probably i haven't
seen any of their decks but i think i've
seen unproven
uh economics uh long-term liabilities
uh what does that mean long time later i
mean landlords aren't like willingly
just like giving up their spaces for
this kind of risky thing there's a bit
of capex you've got a whole bunch of
kids moving in
so a lot of these companies i think we
live was doing this very early
taking master leases on like buildings
so you're taking like tens of millions
of dollars
per building sometimes liability on your
balance sheet because you're promising
them like 10-year leases
ah i don't know if that's like how i'd
sleep well at night now it's a great
business model for some
uh i don't think it's a great business
model even if you have like a six
bedroom mansion in the suburbs
and you're renting it for 12k yep and
you fit six people in it
it's 2 000 a person you're living in a
mansion you get a backyard and a pool
that's kind of cool yep
but there's no profit there yep so i
don't think it's profitable as a
business in and of itself but maybe
micro apartments at scale if you're
building
or renovating buildings that could work
that could work and i think that's the
key point is you kind of got to design
it for like
exactly the community you want to build
but look at hotels like when i stay in
manhattan now to go to our new zombies
new york office
i stand in like a hotel i think called
the arlo where basically the yes
it's the rooms are tiny you can touch
the wall i don't care from your bed
exactly and it's not even that cheap
sadly but it's like cheaper than like
the ridiculous 300 or 400
instead of 800 correct